and welcome to Hannity and tonight part
two of my interview with former
president Donald Trump at Mar-A-Lago now
yesterday we had a very lengthy
wide-ranging conversation that mostly
focused on the unprecedented raid at
Mar-A-Lago and the Fulfillment of New
York attorney general Leticia James
campaign promise to get and go after all
things Trump and the civil suit that she
filed tonight we talk about the issues
that are greatly impacting this country
that we all love the lives of all of you
the American people we're going to talk
about all of that I want to talk about
the midterm elections Joe Biden is he
fit for this office Biden's foreign
policy failures when it comes to China
and Iran and Afghanistan we'll talk
about the covet pandemic taxes energy
the attacks on President Trump's family
and much more I'll also ask him if he
has made up his mind on whether he is
running in 2024. here's a preview
do you worry about putting other people
what Melania had to go through and baron
had to go through do you worry about
putting them back in that situation in
other words I'm going to say put it
nicely you're a golfer yeah why don't
you just play God why why would you want
to give up a great life and go back to
that hellhole because I love the country
and we were so close
now unlike the current occupant of the
Oval Office Trump was able to provide
candid and detailed answers to dozens of
questions and no giant no cards no
teleprompter no confusion at all
whatsoever that we saw at any point at
one point Donald Trump stated that he
wanted Joe Biden your current president
to do a good job wanted him to be
successful in a way that would improve
the lives of the American people
unfortunately Joe is not capable the
results they speak for themselves now
recently Biden said quote watch me proof
of the pudding is in the eating well Joe
we're watching and here's the pudding
Biden wandering aimlessly totally Dazed
and Confused at a public event last
night in New York he doesn't even seem
to know where he is what he's doing
where he's going you decide
God bless you all
[Applause]
uh Mr President thank you that's like a
really bad SNL skit now while Biden is
out there wandering aimlessly his staff
seems to totally ignore him they don't
really care about Joe and for the woke
socialists working in the West Wing he's
a little more than a ballpoint pen
signing off on their radical agenda
that's basically his role they're not
really concerned if he gets lost on
stage or forgets what he's doing or
where he is as long as he does what they
want him to do now Joe Biden has never
been much much of a leader and now with
his obvious transparent cognitive
decline he's little more than a shadow
taking orders from the far left climate
alarmist cultists that rule the
Democratic Socialist new green deal
party now these wealthy Elites are not
concerned with making your life better
or strengthening the American dream
dream instead they want to transition
you and this country into a socialist
Eco state to satisfy their own Twisted
morals and maintain political power in
perpetuity and again as Joe says the
proof is in the pudding now after record
levels of spending on green energy
projects and tuition forgiveness and oh
let's see he was bragging at the U.N
yesterday uh
367 or 69 billion dollars on climate
change 200 billion on food shortage
problems around the world we have an
inflation rate that has had a 40-year
high and going higher after restricting
domestic production of energy oil gas
our capabilities well we've all
witnessed what gas prices doubling
Energy prices through the roof the cost
of everything you buy at every store you
go to cost more everything the southern
border meanwhile is non-existent
Democrats have no problem with millions
of illegal immigrants pouring into our
country tree so long as they stay out of
where they are in New York City in
Washington DC and of course Martha's
Vineyard take a look
there was a bus of migrants that was
dropped off in front of your home also
Governor DeSantis flew migrants from
Texas to Martha's Vineyard can you
understand the political point that
DeSantis and Abbott are trying to make
here
they're playing games he's a political
stunts doing it for the sake of a
headline
what we're seeing with these Governors
is is irresponsible and it's it's
inhumane it's inhumane
well we're having a record year never
before have we had two million people
cross that border and we still have a
long way to go to the end of the year so
according to our borders are it's not
irresponsible or inhumane to lure
millions of illegal immigrants and let
them risk their life and limb to take
that perilous journey to our borders
because they're telling them we'll let
you in they're showing them by letting
everybody in uh that's not irresponsible
or inhumane leaving families homeless
out on the streets in El Paso under
bridges and Del Rio it's not
irresponsible it's not inhumane to
enrich evil cartels allow opioids and
Fentanyl to proliferate all over the
country according to Kamala the real
crisis is Ron DeSantis and Greg Abbott
relocating some of these migrants on a
charted flight in the case of Martha's
Vineyard but of course it's okay when
Biden relocates migrants those late
night flights uh to States all over the
country very obscure airport so nobody
sees the rules don't apply to Democrats
and that's why we now have deeply
corrupt Federal bureaucracy out of
control with a politically motivated
two-tiered system of justice we went
into great detail about that last night
now breaking tonight yet another example
of unequal application of our laws a
September 2018 document from the Obama
Foundation look at what this says I'll
read it to you the Obama Foundation
agrees to transfer up to 3.3 million
dollars to the National Archives to
support the move of classified and
unclassified Obama presidential records
and artifacts from Hoffman Estates to
Nara the National Archives records
Administration controlled facilities
that conform to the agency's archival
storage standards now two key issues one
these documents were stored in an old
furniture warehouse in Hoffman Estates
between a highway and of course that did
not exactly meet archival storage
standards did it and number two this was
September of 2018 nearly two years after
Obama left office in other words there
was a trove of classified documents
according to them from the Obama
Administration removed from the white
house sitting in an old furniture
warehouse why did that not Merit or meet
security standards and maybe a potential
raid no federal rate at those facilities
at all no investigation into Obama at
all no accountability from the National
Archives they if you're a Democrat
you're a liberal your new green deal
socialist you are above the law
apparently as we all know by now it is a
different story when it comes to Trump
or conservatives or Republicans his
house of course was raided by dozens of
Agents guns drawn of course this is only
one of about 30 current and former
investigations into Donald Trump none of
them have brought the fruit that they
hope for and like good comrades in the
old Soviet Union the leftists in Biden's
doj which has now been weaponized and in
New York the Attorney General's office
they aren't investigating crimes instead
they are attempting to destroy one
individual one family one company and
one movement if they are successful The
credibility of our justice system will
never recover that will mean pretty much
Mark Levin's right it will be a
post-constitutional America and the
political weaponization of the rule of
law will only get worse despite all of
this yesterday Donald Trump was composed
he was collected all while his successor
Joe Biden gets flustered at the mere
Prospect of walking off a stage just
think about what you think about we're
no longer in capable hands now that is
why I did ask president Trump if he
plans to run again and challenge Biden
in 2024 or we'll get to that in a moment
but first hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else